second question today hey David wouldn't
free college and healthcare drastically
kneecap military enlistment since lots
of people join the military to get those
things so there's two parts here
question one is whether that would
happen question two is whether it's a
bad thing it is true there are lots of
people who go into the military in the
United States
because they can't afford to go to
college or they are not cut out for
college and the military is one of the
most direct paths to earning a steady
paycheck from a reliable employer there
are other financial reasons and
certainly health care is another thing
that the military provides there are
also arguments which say that if you
improve education in health care and
access to them you would end up with
more people enlisting because they know
they can always go back to getting an
education and they might feel less
pressure to do it right away because
they know that it's always there waiting
for them in some sound sense but I
believe that that is effectively not the
the right way to approach the question
number one fortunately for us we have
more than enough people in our military
and a significantly bigger than
necessary military force so the military
not having enough recruits because
people can go to college or have health
care is not a realistic concern number
two let's go even further though people
who join the military for economic
necessity I don't believe are the people
that I would prefer be in the military
if we don't have a draft which we don't
I want the people in the military to be
people who want to be in the military
not people who have no interest in it
but have no money for education or
health care and they join out of
desperation I don't think that that's
good for the military this is why the
recruiting that the military does in
poor areas going to high schools where
the appeal is simply economic is so
predatory and I will even go further
than that if we had universal health
care you might break the bottleneck that
is the overloaded VA hospital and
improved treatment for veterans by
clearing out the VA facilities a little
bit by allowing people to go elsewhere
education can make it so that when
veterans come back from serving they
have more options for jobs when they
back and they will be better integrated
into society as opposed to often ending
up concentrated in certain fields one
other thing tons of young people aren't
even eligible to enlist because of
health issues including obesity which is
an epidemic in the United States better
educated people are less likely to be
obese overall healthier people with
access to health care are less likely to
be obese it is an interesting
proposition that by providing education
and healthcare to people you will reduce
obesity and increase the number of
people that are medically eligible to
join the military and actually grow the
number of people that are enlisting it's
something to think about so I think that
whenever we we see something like oh
hold on if people no longer need to join
the military because they'd be for
health care or economic reasons the
military will be hurt
well let's first figure out whether
that's true and secondly let's figure
out whether it's actually hurt if
different people or fewer people are
enlisting I think in this case that the
answer seems to be the exact opposite